grammar rules are actually quite simple
they're not going to help you speak but
they're simple it's like chess not
difficult to figure out how chess works
the rules in fact just by watching
people you can kind of tell you know
which pieces are able to move how but an
experienced chess player is going to win
it's not because he knows the rules
better it's because he has so much
experience playing chess he's seen it
all before he can anticipate he's got
memory of games of moves he's got it all
and the language is the same way you
have to get all that experience in you
it's not the rules it's not the grammar
rules it's not the chess rules that are
going to help you do well with the
language you can't shortcut The
Experience lots of listening and reading